there's a game saturday night to get
ready for between the tampa bay
buccaneers and the washington
football team at fedex field the first
playoff game for washington in
five years alex smith starting
quarterback
not completely healthy from the strained
calf here's ron rivera the coach of the
team talking yesterday about the
possibility
of a rotation at quarterback on saturday
night
honestly the thing that we have to be
willing to do and
and we have to really think about is
whether or not to
rotate him in and out with with uh
with taylor i mean we we have to
definitely look at that
you know it's i mean there's nothing you
can do i mean that's the truth of the
matter
we're going to play a very aggressive
defense uh this week
and you know obviously it's something we
most really have to look at
you always think of the rotation by way
of the defensive line and it keeps the
defensive linemen fresh
and it allows them to wreak havoc later
into the game your offensive line
typically doesn't rotate although there
may be a swing guy that comes in from
time to time to get someone to rest
right the idea of actually rotating the
quarterback
that that's that's a new thing but again
it's driven by the health issues that
alex smith has been dealing with
they'd rather have him play but if
having him play
means having him periodically not play
then you know that that's part of what
the coach has to figure out in order to
try to win the game yeah
i mean hey they got to do what they got
to do uh we we both watched alex smith
on sunday night
you know listen this is the first thing
i'm going to say mike and
i mean this and i say this only because
i like the guy
and the person but man i really wish
alex smith would retire and i don't mean
that disrespectfully i mean that because
i care about the guy
and i just i sit there watching him
every game and i honestly
every time he drops back to pass i go
oh gosh don't let him get hit okay i'm i
really sit there
watching him just going i hope he's okay
after this play
after this game after this quarter i i
just gotten to that point
it hasn't ever looked normal to me this
year
yes it's been playable and doable yes
but then even last week you see there's
a little calf injury he couldn't get out
of harm's way
last week that was scary it really was
and i think he knew it
i mean he was one legged hopping
throwing trying to not let his leg get
stuck in the ground or get caught in a
weird position
and what i would say to what we just
heard from ron rivera
is if we're at that point
well so i don't even understand that so
we're at that point what are we going to
do like oh it's a drop back pass taylor
hennike come in heineke come in
oh it's it's a handoff alex smith back
in oh it's a sprint out pass hey it's
taylor again bring him in
if you're at that point to me then just
start taylor just start heneki heineke
henneke i'm all over the place with his
name this morning
but been antonio yeah thank you but that
would be my thought there i don't know
what two quarterback rotation would
really do
mike that's where i i would question it
that there was a comment from bruce
arians also on espn he had made this
remark during
a press conference yesterday when he was
on espn he went even
farther talking about the washington
football team he said we're not playing
a 7-9 team we're playing a four-in-one
team
when alex smith plays they're a
four-in-one team we're not playing
dwayne haskins we're playing alex smith
which
you gotta love bruce sherry yes
seriously in in the twisting at the
at the dwayne haskins debacle but alex
smith isn't what alex smith once was
i still think that he's good enough to
play in the nfl he wouldn't be on the
field if he wasn't
yeah but i agree with you it's almost
it's just that we know what happened to
him
right and so we are more nervous
and more aware of the possibility of
injury to him because of what he went
through
and and uh and at what point
is it not worth it any longer you've
proven to yourself you can get all the
way back
you've proven yourself you can overcome
one of the worst injuries anyone's ever
come in any professional sport ever how
much longer do you go
and then you got tom brady who's 43 and
a half
and i'm starting to think he's not going
to stop when he turns 45
i think he's going to keep pushing the
envelope as far as he can and obviously
he'll be the other quarterback
in that game on saturday night but
look look chris i i haven't seen the the
betting line
recently and we'll be doing the mega pix
podcast tomorrow where we make our picks
i i don't give washington a whole lot
of a chance here but that's why bruce
aryan said what he said
he doesn't want his guys to think all
they have to do is show up
and win the game and and according to
pete demolitis the buccaneers are
currently eight point favorites think
about that eight point road favorites
against washington but you don't want
your guys to be complacent we've seen
that
we've seen that in the nfl we have seen
occasions where a team thinks all it has
to do is show up
and the next thing you know it gets
punched in the mouth and we have a game
and the the underdog ends up stealing it
and so i yeah if i'm the buccaneers i am
leery about what could happen even if
they do rotate quarterbacks you you got
to be
i mean as brady and aryans watch film
the
their their their stress level
or their you know careful approach the
game will
continue to increase because they're
gonna sit there and go wait
holy crap this front four this
washington football team this defense
you know they've had periods this year
where they won games single-handedly by
themselves
asked kyle shanahan and the 49ers 49ers
controlled washington
but oh ch you know strip sack fumble by
daron payne chase young picks it up
returns it for a touchdown you know
strip uh
hit hit the quarterback as he's throwing
ball pops in the air interception
short field washington gets another
touchdown you know
so a play or two like that
and it could be a whole different ball
game and then when you do have alex
smith
and this is the beauty of how he fits in
that football team where oh the defense
got a touchdown and
he won't give the other defense a chance
to even the score
he'll be smart and they'll chip away
from there and all of a sudden you look
up and you go
you know we're the better team but we're
losing by three or
seven points because their defense has
ruined the game for us and
really that's going to be the goal for
tampa is just not to let that front four
and that defense ruin the game for them
and since the game is saturday tuesday
was the first day of
practice and practice reports alex smith
did not practice because of the calf
injury antonio gibson
their starting running back did not
practice because of that turf toe
yeah and terry mclaurin with that ankle
man did not practice
they all played last week but they they
did not practice
and they didn't look normal either mike
mclaurin and gibson they did not uh so
that that that's
troublesome because they need those two
to make plays if they're gonna do
anything because it's not really an alex
smith to make those plays and sorry i
didn't mean to interrupt you with the
buck sorry
that's fine mike evans didn't practice
because he's got that knee injury and we
saw that thing happen live and we
thought he was
done for for the year when the knee
buckled
uh when he slid on the grass in the end
zone and it buckled again
which it just didn't look good so they
said the mri
showed no structural damage he's
day-to-day did not practice yesterday
at least they have antonio brown who
stepped up in a huge way
for the buccaneers on on uh on sunday
against the falcons so they have that
going for them but we'll continue to
monitor the injury reports and again yes
we'll make our our picks on thursday for
that
game although i think we're both leaning
tampa bay
buccaneers especially given what tom
brady has done
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports